in today's video we talk about
thermobaric weapons and their effects on
humans but i make a premise i'm not an
expert and i can't replace those who
have made the study of certain topics a
profession but i can still make myself
useful translate into simple words where
possible complex concepts let's start on
march 1st 2022 a senior u.s defense
official tells journalists the
deployment without specifying the exact
location of tos-1 weapon systems capable
of sending thermobaric rockets against
ukrainian targets a dramatic signal
dictated by the russian need to close
the game as quickly as possible after
the ukrainians have demonstrated a great
ability to resist to a more numerous and
better equipped enemy then the visual
confirmation on the web are circulating
the first videos and images that show
some russian convoys carrying these
little weapons but what exactly is a
thermobaric weapon and on what occasions
has it been used throughout history it's
not easy to give a definition above all
because the term has been improperly
used to include in a single category
different weapon systems and to describe
different effects etymology comes to a
rescue the greek words thermos and varus
respectively heat and pressure describe
well the effects of these weapons very
high temperature and dynamic
overpressure or shockwave in the
simplest terms a thermobaric munition is
a type of enhanced explosive munition
that produces the typical effect of a
conventional high temperature explosion
but by consuming the oxygen present in
the air creates a much greater shock
wave thus increasing the lethality zone
and going to hit victims who are located
further away from the epicenter of the
detonation i open and close the
parenthesis thermobaric weapon and fuel
air weapon are not synonymous they are
two species of the same genre enhanced
blast weapons because their operating
principle is different but the effects
are the same a typical thermobaric
device consists of a container of a fuel
mixture that houses a small explosive
burst to charge called a dispersal
charge after the mixture is dispersed as
a cloud and mixes with the surrounding
oxygen the charge causes it to ignite
creating a larger shock wave that does
enormous damage literally crashing
personnel in the immediate vicinity to
death according to a 1993 study by the
u.s defense intelligence agency the
methods of killing against the living
targets are diverse and brutal what
kills is obviously the pressure wave and
subsequent vacuum of oxygen which
collapses the lungs but the victims will
also be severely burned and likely to
breathe in the burning toxic fuel the
same agency in another paper speculates
that because the shock and pressure
waves cause minimal damage to brain
tissue it's possible that victims are
not rendered unconscious by the blast
but instead suffer for several seconds
or minutes while they suffocate but it
doesn't end there outside the area of
the cloud the shock wave travels very
fast and can hit even those who are
beyond the range of the explosion
causing them serious injuries to
internal organs think that the pressure
that is created is up to two times
greater than that generated by a
conventional explosive weapon this is
confirmed by a study of the central
intelligence agency of the united states
for which the effect of such an
explosion in confined spaces is immense
those near the ignition point are
obliterated those at the fringe are
likely to suffer many internal and thus
invisible injuries in addition to
collapsing lungs there is talk of
embolisms in blood vessels
bleeding and lacerations that can lead
to peritonitis ruptured ear drums and
displacement of ice from their sockets
it's not an exaggeration to say that
such devices can have the effects of a
tactical nuclear weapon without the
disadvantage of producing radiations
because of the mixture's ability to
easily creep into any cavity there is
nothing that can protect against its
devastating effects neither natural
terrain features nor field
fortifications that are intermedically
sealed indeed the ideal use is precisely
against enclosed structures such as
bunkers or buildings since the cloud by
sucking in materials nearby to fill the
oxygen void amplifies the destruction of
the structure's load-bearing elements as
reported by a russian military scientist
writing for the military magazine by
anya thermobaric weapons are also
effective in eliminating minefields and
completely destroying the vegetation of
a certain area to make room for
helicopter landing sites in fact the us
first experimented with this system in
the 1960s in vietnam with the famous and
massive daisy cutter bomb capable of
clearing entire sections of forest in
general the category of enhanced
explosive weapons has found use on
several occasions the us used them in
1991 during the first gulf war then in
2001 in afghanistan in an attempt to
flush out al qaeda members sheltering in
the mountains of torabora and more
recently in 2017 against isil members in
the afghan region of nangarhar the
russians on the other hand tested
several thermobaric systems in 1969
during the border conflict with china
then it was the turn of attacks on the
afghan panchi valley in the early 1980s
against massoud's forces and more
recently as interfax reported between
october and december 1999 during the
offensive against the chechen forces in
the direction of the capital grozny
during the russian advance to take the
city two main thermobaric launch systems
were used the devastating toss one also
called buratino which we hear so much
about these days operational since the
early 80s during the soviet afghan war
and developed by the transmasch design
office enomsk it's a 220 millimeters
multiple rocket launcher system mounted
on a t-72 tank chassis its maximum
effective range is 3.5 kilometers but
other sources say it could reach 5
kilometers the other afghanistan veteran
much smaller in size clearly is the
single shot rpoh smell shoulder mounted
launcher with the claimed maximum range
of one kilometer in the maximum
effective range of 600 meters this type
of weapon is at its best when used as a
bunker buster and loses some
effectiveness when used against
dispersed troops in the open field
normally killing no more than a couple
in bursts when used against the armored
vehicles however it usually damages the
vehicle but the crew survives and is
able to return fire to conclude it
remains to be understood if there are
international treaties that prohibit or
limit the production or use of such
weapons unfortunately not but this
doesn't mean that there are no arguments
against their development as reported by
human rights watch since the enhanced
blast weapons cover a very large area
they are prone to indiscriminate use
especially in or near populated areas in
urban settings it's very difficult to
direct the effect of these weapons only
to militaries without involving
civilians because of their very nature
and then for the fact that covering
every corner or crevice make it
virtually impossible for civilians to
take shelter from their destructive
effect so even if a thermobaric weapon
is aimed at a military target its
extensive and uncontrollable effect
doesn't exclude the involvement of
civilian victims and these that is the
use of weapons in attacks that can't
distinguish between militaries and
civilians is prohibited by the geneva
conventions of 1899 and 1907. however
efforts have not yet produced concrete
results given that the 1980 convention
prohibiting the production of certain
conventional weapons deals with
incendiary weapons in which category
however thermobaric weapons would not
fall and if we look at the current
conflict between russia and ukraine the
problem doesn't only concern the
possible use of these weapons but also
of the so-called cluster munitions and
obviously of the fear the nuclear
warheads some suspect that russia has
already used the former despite the
existence of an international convention
of 2008 that prohibits them and that
moscow although not a signatory has
always respected the possible use of the
russian nuclear arsenal instead which
now counts almost 6 000 warheads is
certainly the most worrying given the
recent threats of president putin to use
them if any power should interfere
militarily well we are done for today i
thank you all for your attention and see
you in the next video ciao